Speaking of antisemitism, we have had another
attack that fits the bill, a former black
Israel light. I will explain what that means
in a second. A shot up a kosher market in
Jersey city, New Jersey. Yesterday, six people
were shot dead total, including two shooters,
five of them in the kosher grocery store called
JC kosher supermarket. One of the perpetrators
previously wrote many antisemitic things on
social media according to law enforcement
and is reportedly a former black Israelite,
the black Israelite movement. Uh, we will
get to that in a moment. The, the perpetrator
had been previously arrested in 2004 2007
on weapons charges and 2009 for criminal mischief.
So what is this black Israelite thing? Uh,
black Israelites are a fixture. Often when
you come out of the subway in New York city,
they will proselytize there.
I have been approached by black Israelites
when I lived in New York city. Black Israelites
are sometimes called black Hebrews, and generally
speaking, I want to do as good a job of accurately
but not over-represented what they believe.
Black Israelites claim to be the real Jews.
Now, they are not Ethiopian Jews. They're
Ethiopian Jews or something else. And if you
don't know about that, it's not today's subject,
but black Israelites or something else, they
claim to be the actual and true descendants
of the biblical children of Israel. The individuals
described in the Bible, they say that other
Jews, what are colloquially known as white
Jews are imposters. They're not really Jewish.
They're not really the descendants of the
people in the Bible. They are considered a
black nationalist group. The likes of the
nation of Islam, of course, with very different
fundamental beliefs as you can probably imagine
here.
And um, what we are realizing is that antisemitism
is a very real and growing 21st century problem.
And you might say, well, but David, hold on.
How can people who say that they are the real
Jews be antisemitic? You can claim to be anything
you want. If your fundamental belief is that
white Jews are devilishly imposters who deserve
death or slavery, that's antisemitic. And
this is a growing problem. Unfortunately in
the U S and around the world. I recently mentioned
this and um, there, there are so many different
reports about it. Some of which I'll tell
you about right now. The European union agency
for fundamental rights has a report out which
finds pervasive antisemitism in Europe visibly.
So in some places where public harassment
is actually commonplace in France, the CNC,
D H has a big report about the growth of antisemitism
in France. Uh, Germany saw a 20% rise in antisemitic
crime in 2018.
Most of it comes unsurprisingly from far right
groups. The community security trust has a
report out which found the highest number
of antisemitic incidents ever in the United
Kingdom in 2018 the 2019 AJC survey of antisemitism
in America finds that American Jews are feeling
less safe than they've felt in a very long
time. And then the anti defamation league
in 2018 recorded the third highest number
of antisemitic incidents in American history
over the four decades that they have tracked
this. That's how far back that goes. And what
does Donald Trump do? Well, as I told you
earlier, he says, let's pass an executive
order to label Judaism and nationality, which
is not only completely incorrect on facts,
it is also absolutely counterproductive and
only furthers this antisemitic trope of Jewish
dual loyalty by suggesting that an American
Jew born in the U S who maybe has never even
been to Israel, as most Jews, I believe, have
not, uh, might have something in their nationality
that is anything other than simply being an
American person.
We already talked about that this incident
at the kosher market, uh, in Jersey city is
absolutely a horrible one. And for some reason
there were people contacting me saying I wouldn't
cover this incident because the perpetrator
was black and not white. I have that. I don't
know what other shows are doing cause I don't
watch other shows. But shying away from stories
on this program be newsworthy stories based
on the identity of the perpetrators or victims.
That is not something that we have done. We've
been doing this show for a long time. Uh,
and that is not something that I do. We'll
address that later in the [inaudible]
voicemail segment. We'll take a quick break.
Uh, the latest from Tucker Carlson coming
up and many more things that I want to discuss
with you today.